hey coach um I just wanted to ask you
about the evolution of your scheme uh in
terms of you know you started off last
year running I suppose kind of kamakazi
style rpos with t are making sort of
first level reads but pushing the ball
vertically down the field with post post
wheel and rail wheel and and and into
year
two the evolution has been so quick um
and now you're you're much more
condensed between the numbers um the
route deps look a bit different in terms
of yeah but like how awesome is this
like clearly you have an accent and you
know exactly what you're talking about
so um I I'm honored that you that you're
watching our tape um but like you know
there are even some sort of you know
Mike Shanahan elements in terms of two
are turning his back to the defense off
a play now now you're just flexing now
I'm just flexing yeah